[Music]
all right in Royal Drummond news
submitted by Cindy Kim Meghan Marco and
Prince Harry suit the world by stating
their intention to leave the royal
family Prince Andrew that's what I want
to know who's Prince Andrew Prince
Andrew is the kiddy diddler bro I think
that they know some [ __ ] and they're
like we're [ __ ] out cuz you guys you
guys have been down and covering up all
this [ __ ] that's been going all over
these years we're [ __ ] done with the
royal family [ __ ] that's what I think
my own conspiracy corner right now no
you're out of the crew support you are
not invited you didn't do it oh that's
cute I thought it was like I don't know
I'm just stupid like who alright so have
you guys heard the Royal drama I saw the
the title story too wasn't there
originally row double with her because
how she's not black okay okay wait
making more girls why she's not black
she is half like a wait really yes you
don't think this is my crazy like that
babysoul white cuz he am in distress
I didn't know yeah yeah she looks like a
Alicia Keys yeah huh okay see the back
in her Steve doesn't see color you guys
stop it truly don't
that's the Queen let me tell you so she
looks like a gerbil
she does she like I said the N word a
lot
she doesn't like with that hair web like
I don't know that nigger's her just
coming up feeding the geese and that's
an accent
huh she has an accent well I mean she
drops it when she's in the house like
the Queen all all the geese all of them
belong to the crew they're huge man
really like you like we're not getting
into key stuff okay geese for hours have
you played the entitled all right so
ever since Megan and Harry started
dating since the beginning the UK press
has been coming after Meg like hardcore
so um it just has gotten to the point
where they're like [ __ ] this was [ __ ]
now peace out so okay yes Megan is half
black she is also an American and she's
also a divorced American American which
in the past when royal because like
Queen Elizabeth's uncle I believe her
uncle abdicated the throne because he
fell in love with a divorce one American
woman and so that's why she became Queen
because he abdicated but yeah
so they have a thing against divorced
women forced and used goods pretty much
pretty much like princess died she was
divorced no no but they were talking
about separating and then oh no you know
cheating on her and she's the one
getting the [ __ ] I don't get it
oh well she's gonna be a divorced woman
that's why yeah yeah and then that's
that's why they had to kill her
alleged spear sees that was why I know
it anyway okay so back to Meg here
stallion so this all started so back in
2016
Prince Harry from the Kensington Palace
Twitter they ended up issuing a
statement pretty much Ted like Harry
telling the press like hey back the [ __ ]
up
back the [ __ ] up from my girl okay yeah
yeah I'm going after her so then um and
then it also got a little messy because
Megan's father which is her whites
bucking [ __ ] he's an [ __ ] apparently
because he likes set up this like secret
like press like paparazzi thing he likes
attention yes attention warts so anyway
I know I see you stuff not yet she's
trying to get through these you're
trying to lose twenty thirty pounds I
was like so I picked them up it will be
stuck that way the butter started
licking it like it it wasn't good okay
I'm trying to do is just as the prank
guys go back it's silly case Oh
anyway huge dude alright so anyway so
her entirely Papa your talk about her
Papa yes shady as bear yes so they like
she's already dealing with drama because
of that and then she ends up getting
pregnant and everyone they started this
hashtag I forgot what it was called but
it was like something like pretty much
thing that Meg's not pregnant and that
she was hiding it that she was faking it
hello weird and just it's not hard to
get pregnant as she was pretending to be
pregnant just so she could fully like I
don't know gold dig I got crown big
crown dig and then they're even saying
that she was like buying oh the hash I
was Megan Markel is not pregnant that
was Jenna
[ __ ] life oh yes and then if you're
royalty can't just order them I command
you to leave me alone they'll have real
power they also have this like agreement
with the royal press or something and so
they got so pissed off after this whole
announcement because they were like what
the [ __ ]
we're supposed to have access to your
lives we're supposed to report on you
whatever instance Harry and maybe we're
like mmm then they got pissed anyway
that was a good bird good flip off
Thanks so then last year there were
rumors that there was a growing rift
between Harry and his brother William
and there was also a whole bunch of
rumors saying that Cates which is Prince
William's wife Kate Middleton and Meg
were having a royal tiff and so they
were just there was all these rumors did
they live they were they all live at
Buckingham Palace I'm wondering no they
had like their own they have their own
houses and [ __ ] that's all subsidized by
the [ __ ] poor Brits man they got to
pay hundreds of millions of dollars a
year anything but they love it they love
all this drama they love all this they
love it I don't think they do
are you sure I don't think they all love
it I think I don't think they all love
it
do they live in castles no they live in
a powerful they live in a palace
this is blocked off - where where the
living quarters are the living quarters
parts are completely separate from life
Windsor Windsor Castle so anyway so
heavy just sneak out the back in a
haystack like a horse-drawn carriage
chase that thing yeah nobody would
notice I'm leaving you know they tried
it but then they got caught yeah
Buckingham Palace for Christmas Harry
and Megan spent their Christmas overseas
this past Christmas and the Queen had
like her her you annual Christmas royal
address or whatever and she always sits
in front of this desk and that desk
always has family portraits mmm
this last Christmas Megan Harry
Archie which is her new baby like
newborn baby we're missing and also
Prince Andrew was missing well he should
you should for sure what but filth so
then straight removing pictures this
year is when Harry and Megan announced
that they will no longer be so they're
saying quote we have chosen to make a
transition this year and starting to
carve out a progressive new role within
this institution we intend to step back
as senior members of the royal family
and work to become financially
independent while continuing to fully
support Her Majesty the Queen
it is with your encouragement
particularly over the last three years
that we feel prepared to make this
adjustment now we now plan to balance
our time between the United Kingdom and
North America continuing to honor our
duty to the Queen the Commonwealth and
our patronage is so they're saying that
they like they're planning on splitting
their time between Canada and the UK and
that oh and then they're saying the
Royal people they were saying that the
Queen had no idea that no one there at
the palace of whatever knew that they
were gonna be announcing this and they
were completely blindsided what does
this mean though if I say am I not to
say sire anymore we don't have to say
[ __ ] then what is it how does it apply
to me it doesn't it's just it's all pomp
and circumstance and ceremony and all
his horseshit it's cold it's like the
Royal Kardashian drama but then if
they're leaving the family they're not
royal anymore so now they're out there
okay you can't spit on anyone for all
commoners I could spit on everybody if I
spin gonna get my head cut off or
something Jesus why your abs like take
them
m-net off with their heads crazy
[ __ ] is like even after they get married
and even after the baby they would still
like that girl should go back to the
stage hardcore bullymail to the like I'm
gonna show you guys some comparisons
okay so here's Harry man the cut like
that's the citizen saying that or you
know it's the press press all the and on
Twitter because they're just going off
of it so here's some comparison so this
is how they treated Kate and it's how
they treated Meg so for Kate it says not
long ago pregnant came to pregnant
Kate's tenderly cradles her baby bump
while wrapping up her royal duties ahead
of maternity leave and William confer
just do any minute now so she's it's all
Pleasant they're pointing out like how
oh she's cradling her belly but for
Megan they right
why can't Megan Marco keeps off like a
[ __ ] off her baby bump or of her bump
experts tackled a question that has
gotten the nation talking is it pride
vanity acting or a new-age bonding
technique who the [ __ ] is an expert on
if a person is too prideful cuz they're
holding their baby I will say what do
you go to school for that on the left
she's holding it you know just holding a
little bit on the right she's holding it
like a [ __ ] she has both hands on to be
very [ __ ] evil way to Bowl this just
like an example to show you like how
different they treats Kate and Meg in
the UK so apparently Megan when it's
Harry and said listen this is not
working for me well we need to figure
some [ __ ] out I don't want to raise my
kid in this environment so good that's
healthy I wanna raise my kid in the
royal family you know right in all these
castles and [ __ ] who is it we out we're
going to Canada [ __ ] that build our own
finances like mother [ __ ] still rich
like I'm sure you won't get like all the
money was supposed to but I'm sure he's
not gonna be her I went from a hundred
million to 10 million
they're just like listen we don't want
your [ __ ] money yeah we don't want
this [ __ ] [ __ ] beat Sal we're
doing we're making our own money to
Canada and kid is gonna pay for us
actually Canada's largest newspaper they
email with this gaming editorial but
that suppose to be nice yes so they were
saying that they they cannot live in
Canada because it's unconstitutional
what does that mean and there's like a
whole less explanation of this but the
penis they're saying as long as they're
they remain senior Royals or like
they're part of the royal family they
think they just can't live in Canada
you're not welcome in Canada I never
would have thought Canada would have
said that well if it's coming from an
editorial like oh like not not actually
starting to build a case
yeah yeah that's weak as [ __ ] right look
I don't want the rules anywhere do you
huh
I don't want the rules anywhere do you
hmm call back to your castle yeah that's
what I say
Lucy no no she don't know like the
castle yeah you know go back to your
[ __ ] gasps okay you get out of my
diner
I mean Canada yeah
this is Canada we got yeah [ __ ] lot
of syrup I guess
[Laughter]
[Music]
[Music]